I want to talk about Governor Nome want
to thank him he's been one hell of a
governor
man matter of fact he could be anything
you want he could have the job I'm
looking
for all right here's some advice Joe if
you're running for president don't
suggest that other people you think
might actually be better at the job
joining me now Jesse Waters host of
waters prime time here on Fox
News Jesse I think this is the first
time we've been on set together correct
it's beautiful let's make it last it's
so good to see you good to see you too
what what do you think of the the the
agulation going from Biden to Nome and
then X to Nome and Nome to X it's quite
a triangle it's a love triangle and G is
winning yeah as she always does so if I
was kamla I'd be livid because Joe Biden
just endorsed Gavin Nome so so she's
probably crying somewhere and I've never
felt bad for her she or she she you know
this is like who's on first who Who's
Crying Now but Gavin Nome fell in love
with G when he went to China he saw the
Tobin he saw the intertwined tree he ran
over children playing basketball and he
just had the best time of his life so
when she came back to San Francisco he
thought it was just going to be she and
Nome but then Biden comes in and Biden
gives G everything he wants oh is there
even a deal that Joe Biden got with the
Chinese oh they're curbing the fent
they're curbing the fentanyl yes because
we trust China every time they promise
something so I don't know what if CH is
playing the two off of each other
whatever he's doing it's working and
we're losing um well Jesse you know our
colleague was supposed to be with us
Sean because I think it's like you know
the three of us have never appeared
together but he was busy he was busy and
he wanted to be here especially just to
hang out with you but um we went looking
for him we did this is what happens when
you don't join us
okay where are my
footballs I got to have a lot of
footballs let not your heart be
troubled you're a great
American but where are my
footballs I love you Sean you're so
awesome but you're not
here where's the greatness where's the
greatness well oh Sean you know you have
to tease is this like when they do a
state of the union and one member of the
cabinet isn't there oh they go to an
undisclosed location yes that's what
we're doing here because we can't all be
together in the same no that would also
be a bad thing but how you like an 8:00
I like 8:00 uh my dinner situations
Chang I know both of ours with our
famili and I haven't quite gotten over
it I have to eat dinner with my
assistant Johnny in my office oh that's
that that is that's always fun instead
of my wife and children so that's that's
probably the worst part about it but
everything else has been well it's so
great to see you and I they tell me I
have to get off the stage fast because
someone's hosting a show after this one
who wait oh that would be me Laura great
to see you have a great show all right
great to see you Jesse love you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else